state versus state warfare is rare today
replaced by insurgencies and
unconventional conflicts
as you're listening to me i'm confident
that somewhere in the world there's an
insurgency or a civil war raging
since the time of world war ii far more
people have been fighting their own
governments or inside a particular state
than in wars between states
conventional war still occurs as in the
arab israeli wars
but they tend to be short and intense
without changing the map very much
if you looked at a graph of people
killed in battle since world war ii the
trend line is bumpy but it definitely
points downward
has conventional war government versus
government conflict become obsolete
some serious thinkers suggest that it is
dying out
among the prominent theories is that
socioeconomic change and globalization
have tied economies and societies
together
also might the pain of loss from today's
smaller families with fewer young men to
spare make societies less eager for war
one expression of this thinking is known
as the mcdonald's theory of war that no
two countries with a mcdonald's fast
food restaurant have ever gone to war
it's not that the meals are magic
the idea is that if your economy is
sophisticated enough to support a
mcdonald's it's sophisticated enough to
not fight another such society
the problem with this idea is that it is
flatly wrong
there have been at least a half dozen
mcdonald's wars out there where both
sides had mcdonald's restaurants
examples
in 1989 the united states invaded panama
in 1999 nato went to war against serbia
and pakistan fought india
these were all mcdonald's wars
in 2006 israel invaded lebanon
russia fought georgia in 2008 and
against ukraine in 2014.
these were mcdonald's wars too
but what if we get away from focusing on
fast food and instead ask the question
of whether economic ties mean that
countries won't go to war
there's some appeal to this premise
if you think that big business runs
everything then big business might not
want to mess up the smooth functioning
of the world economy
even if you're less conspiratorial it
makes intuitive sense that a country
wouldn't want to go to war with a close
trading partner
the problem though is that the
historical evidence for this is also
weak
look at world war one
the world economy was already highly
globalized and interdependent at the
time
the war started between serbia and
austria-hungary
and serbia's exports were dominated by
the food it sent to austria
germany's biggest trading partners were
britain and russia
and it went to war with both of them
so economic ties seemed to be no
guarantee against war
even if rational calculation states that
going to war is costly
sometimes political leaders aren't
driven by the rational calculations of
profit and loss
there's also the democratic peace theory
which suggests that two democracies are
unlikely to fight
so the gradual spread of democracy makes
the world safer
this is an old idea going back to the
18th century german philosopher emmanuel
kant
he argued that in democracies the people
who choose to go to war are the people
who suffer
so democracy means peace
now this is true as a general tendency
but as a practical guide it's less
useful than you might think
democracies do rarely fight against one
another
but democracies fight non-democracies
all the time think of all the wars the
united states has waged
and the pattern of non-conflict is
strongest for long-established
democracies
new democracies that haven't quite fully
consolidated how they're going to do
things can be more violent
and for that matter what exactly is a
democracy
up until the 1920s women were not
allowed to vote in most places around
the world
so do we count as democracies the
societies where only men or only white
men vote
well if we narrow things to only places
with full suffrage for all adults then
our universe of examples gets a lot
smaller and less impressive
to illustrate the point
if we accept the premise that a
democracy is a place where more or less
all men can vote
then there are some really big and
important wars that look a lot like
democracies fighting each other
under that logic the u.s civil war was a
war between two democracies
both sides let white men vote and sent
out largely white men to get killed
in world war one all the great powers
had elected legislatures
and while russia and germany were not
perfect democracies each had elections
and those elections mattered
so you'd have to be careful with your
definitions to explain why world war one
is not democracies fighting each other
and if you do too much of that it looks
like you're torturing your definitions
to get the result you want
my problem with the democratic peace
theory is that it doesn't help us much
with the questions we really care about
if you tell me
prosperous long-standing democracies
don't go to war with each other my
response is thanks for nothing
nobody's really worried about the united
states going to war with canada or
denmark going to war with sweden
it doesn't help us with the real
problems we face
of all the theories out there for why
war has gotten less common since 1945
the one that seems to me to have the
most merit though it's no guarantee is
called the nuclear peace
this is something of a paradox
the presence of nuclear weapons puts a
limit on how destructive wars can be
if wars were to get out of hand their
destructive potential could eliminate
the entire human species
so that limits how destructive we can
get in actual practice
what political objective can possibly
justify the end of the human race
now we need to be clear about the
limitations of this kind of thinking
first nuclear powers have started wars
with non-nuclear powers
the united states settled for a
stalemate in korea and lost in vietnam
even though it possessed nuclear weapons
in both cases north korea and vietnam
had backing from big powers with nuclear
weapons of their own
so the united states could
understandably fear escalation and
retaliation
but even when losing lives in a
deteriorating situation such as
afghanistan the united states did not
use nuclear weapons
part of that was a lack of good targets
but it's also a matter of political
goals
wars are fought to achieve some
political goal
and it's hard to see how using nuclear
weapons gets you towards a political
objective
flipping this around
it's also true that non-nuclear powers
have attacked nuclear-armed states
israel has never confirmed nor denied
that it has nuclear weapons but all
informed observers agree that israel
does possess them
that was reasonably clear even back in
1973 when egypt initiated a war against
israel
egypt seems to have trusted that israel
wouldn't use its nuclear weapons unless
israel's very existence were at stake
and egypt kept its objectives strictly
limited
finally nuclear-armed states have fought
each other on multiple occasions
soviet pilots and anti-aircraft gunners
shot down american airmen during the
korean war
and brought down perhaps as many as 200
spy plane crew members flying over
soviet territory
the soviet union and china fought a
border war in the late 1960s
and pakistan launched the cargill war
against india in 1999 when both sides
had demonstrated nuclear weapons
the point is that nuclear weapons don't
guarantee peace
having said all that what could we
possibly mean by a nuclear piece
here's what i have in mind
the presence of nuclear weapons makes a
direct attack by a nuclear power against
another nuclear power so risky and
dangerous that it's hard to imagine any
rational leader trying it
it does seem that the presence of
nuclear weapons rules out the conscious
decision to start a particular kind of
war
where the vital national interests of a
nuclear power might be threatened
border skirmishes are one thing like the
soviet chinese conflict in the 1960s
most of india and pakistan's clashes and
egypt's attack on israel in 1973 fall
into those categories as well
the stakes are relatively small so they
don't rise to a level justifying nuclear
weapons
but the scenarios for world war iii a
russian invasion of western europe or a
bolt out of the blue nuclear attack
those represent direct threats to the
vital interests of a nuclear power and
could easily even probably provoke a
nuclear response
accidental war is also a possibility
what about a malfunctioning sensor that
mistakenly reports an incoming nuclear
strike as happened during the cold war
or what about miscalculation and
escalation
a small scale war gets bigger through
tit for tat retaliation until one side's
red line gets crossed and nuclear
weapons are used
what if a nuclear power bluffs by
threatening nuclear use and that bluff
gets called
to my mind that's the most likely way
that an india-pakistan conflict could go
nuclear
to finish this exercise let's run
through some nightmare scenarios of how
we might still stumble into a great
power war
let me be clear these are hypotheticals
and solely my own thinking my scenarios
are based on no inside information and
are unlikely to explode into reality in
the near term
but the enormous consequences of great
power war require us to think seriously
about how to prevent large-scale
conflicts
my scenarios will focus on russia and
china
first russia
there is no possibility of the u.s and
nato initiating a war with russia
russians sometimes find that hard to
believe but it's quite clear
the downsides are enormous and in any
event nato works by consensus
that a couple dozen nato countries would
agreed to start an aggressive war is not
in the cards
so how could things go bad
in the past russia has had a pattern of
aggressive behavior against some of its
neighbors
in georgia in 2008 and in ukraine in
2014
russia used armed force to strip
territory away from a neighboring state
in 2008 the georgians did russia the
favor of shooting first but the russians
took full advantage of the situation
in each case russia created headaches
for a potentially hostile neighboring
state by creating territorial disputes
that made it difficult or impossible for
the neighbor to join nato
and russia scored some domestic
political points
further because neither georgia nor
ukraine were under nato's collective
defense umbrella russia could keep each
conflict limited
does this create the potential for
future dangers
i think so with some important
first vladimir putin has more or less
exhausted the possibilities of scoring
easy victories for domestic political
gain
trying another short war would be much
tougher
russia's remaining neighbors are either
friendly or subservient or would be much
more difficult to swallow
or most importantly they have the
protection of nato membership
it's hard to imagine putin or anyone
else in the kremlin making a deliberate
decision to start a war with nato
while russia might be able to mass land
forces in a particular place for a quick
local victory say for example in the
baltic states
nato's overall military advantages plus
its economic levers make long-term
success almost impossible for russia to
achieve
that's in addition to a lack of concrete
economic benefits to russia
the territorial enclaves from georgia
under russia's protection
plus the crimea and dunbas regions of
ukraine cost russia more to prop up than
any economic benefit received
so it's hard to imagine that a rational
calculation of costs and benefits would
lead the kremlin to view war with nato
and the baltics as a good idea
that said it's also hard to make a
rational cost-benefit calculation on the
wars that russia has already fought
russia lost big from the sanctions
imposed after its fight with ukraine and
was stuck with propping up some money
losing territories
clearly something else was coming into
play quite likely russia's perception of
being under threat from the west and
putin's ability to turn quick foreign
policy successes into higher domestic
approval ratings
thinking about it this way it is
possible to imagine a scenario in which
the kremlin is under siege from a
popular movement
and decides it needs to distract its
public from a domestic crisis with a
foreign policy adventure
although the possibility of triggering
war with nato would be high risk
a future russian government might see a
higher risk from its own population
likewise a russian regime that fears a
nato preemptive strike
something vladimir putin's russian
government certainly talked about
might respond to the potential
deployment of nato offensive systems to
russia's borders with a preemptive
strike of its own
accompanied by threats of nuclear
escalation should nato respond
that might be enough to split the nato
alliance and create the space for russia
to imagine achieving victory
all this calls for careful sober
well-thought-out policies discouraging
russia from further aggressive actions
towards its neighbors
while at the same time not backing
russia into a corner and provoking rash
and desperate actions that make everyone
worse off
let's close by looking at china's
relationship with the rest of the world
and judge how likely a war with china
might be
this scary possibility is relatively new
during the final 20 years of the cold
war the united states and china were de
facto allies against the soviet union
the soviet union had been initially
china's patron and protector
but mao zedong chafed under the idea of
being in second place and was willing to
live with that only so long as joseph
stalin was in power in the soviet union
stalin had legitimacy and seniority in
the world communist movement
after stalin's death in 1953
mao saw himself as the natural successor
to communism's elder statesman
the soviets of course didn't see it that
way
a rapid breakdown in the soviet chinese
partnership resulted
the two quickly became enemies on
personal ideological and territorial
grounds
in 1969 this turned into a brief
undeclared border war over an island in
the usuri river which marks part of
their boundary
relations got so bad that the soviet
government approached the administration
of u.s president richard nixon with a
hypothetical
how would the u.s government react if
the soviets were to carry out a
preemptive nuclear strike to take out
chinese nuclear weapons installations
nixon replied that he did not think this
was a good idea
so when nixon opened up relations with
china in 1971
the united states and china were acting
in effect
as allies against what they perceived as
a far more important threat from the
soviet union
this relationship lasted through the end
of the cold war
when the united states shifted its
diplomatic relations from taiwan to
mainland china
it nevertheless retained a vague defense
commitment to taiwan
but u.s china disagreements about taiwan
didn't seem that important in an
atmosphere where both sides saw the
soviet union as the chief threat
after the cold war ended the united
states and china lost that common enemy
and their political relations began a
slow decline
china's brutal suppression of its
pro-democracy movement at tiananmen
square in 1989 did not play well in the
west
meanwhile as china's economy continued
to grow
it saw itself as deserving a bigger
place on the world stage and the united
states as an obstacle to that
the long-standing issue of taiwan made
matters worse
china saw taiwan as a rebellious
breakaway province that should be
returned to chinese rule
but the united states had committed
itself to the independence of taiwan
even though it broke official relations
with taiwan as part of warming up to
china
in 1996 the chinese launched missiles
into the waters around taiwan to too
intimidated into accepting a return to
china
the united states responded by sending
naval carrier battle groups to the
region
and china couldn't do anything about it
it lacked the military capability then
to consider challenging the us naval
presence
china learned a lesson however
and began the long process of building
an ability to project power around the
region its defense spending began a long
and steady rise
what does this imply about the
possibilities of a war with china
first
china has already started three
substantial wars with neighbors when it
felt its rights and prerogatives were
being infringed
china went to war with india in 1962
over border disputes
even though the territories involved
were remote and had little economic
value
china gave india a bloody nose made its
point and ended the fight
in 1969 china initiated border
skirmishes with the soviet union
and tensions remained high until both
sides agreed to a border settlement
in 1979 china fought a brief border war
with vietnam
vietnam had invaded cambodia to throw
out the vicious and genocidal regime of
pol pot and his khmer rouge party
pol pot was a mass murderer but he was a
chinese client and that mattered
after a short and bloody war
china decided the vietnamese had been
taught a lesson and withdrew
the point of all this is that china has
a pattern of using war as a tool when it
believes its territorial integrity or
prestige are at stake
what makes the situation with taiwan so
dangerous is that taiwan touches on both
questions
from china's point of view taiwan is an
integral part of the country
albeit ruled by a rebellious and
illegitimate government
in fact for many decades taiwan was
ruled by the late chiang kai-shek's
guomendong party which didn't agree with
mainland china's communists on very much
what both sides did agree on was that
taiwan was an integral part of china
they just disagreed on which government
was the legitimate ruler of china
to the chinese communists in beijing
they were the legitimate government of
all china to the guomendang in taiwan it
was them
the question of who was right could be
settled by war but neither side was
willing to risk that step
the small island of taiwan lacked the
resources to conquer the mainland
and mainland china then lacked the
military capability to carry out a very
difficult amphibious invasion
especially when taiwan enjoyed the
implicit backing of the united states
two developments political and military
have since made that uneasy peace harder
to sustain
on the political side nationalism is
growing on both sides but in different
ways
on the mainland china's ruling regime
has used chinese nationalism to unite
the population behind the communist
party and hold off demands for political
change
taiwan's situation is slightly different
the political generation that fled the
mainland at the end of china's civil war
in 1949 is long gone
today more and more taiwanese think of
themselves as quite distinct from china
with their own society
younger taiwanese view the claim that
taiwan is an integral part of china as
somewhat ridiculous
taiwan is a prosperous democracy and
beijing's authoritarian rule is not
attractive
the problem is that beijing has made
clear that if taiwan were ever to
declare itself independent that would be
grounds for war
on the military side china increasingly
possesses the power to make victory in
such a war possible
china's economic growth has been
invested in its navy and air force
if war came between china and taiwan it
would present the united states with a
difficult problem
the u.s has followed a path of strategic
ambiguity
it's suggested that taiwan's security is
important to it and that it would accept
only a peaceful resolution of the
mainland's disputes with taiwan
on the other hand the united states has
not made an explicit guarantee that it
would go to war to defend taiwan
its goal is to discourage china from a
military solution
the united states continues to muster
far more military capability than china
in the aggregate
but a war over taiwan would be fought in
china's neighborhood
the taiwan strait is only a hundred
miles across so china would have full
use of its land-based systems while the
united states would largely be operating
from the sea
china could also use a nuclear bluff
would the united states be willing to
risk a nuclear exchange for taiwan's
sake
without question a u.s china war would
be a human and economic catastrophe
and the uneasy status quo is better than
war if you look at the situation from
the standpoint of profit and loss
but political leaders don't always think
in those terms
thucydides the ancient greek historian
suggested that international relations
are governed by fear honor and interest
while material interests suggest that
war is a terrible idea
the countervailing fear of political
upheaval at home
or the commitment to national honor and
integrity
might push things in another direction
and there's always the risk of a mistake
or miscalculation that produces an
outcome no one wants
with china as with russia the key for
the united states and the west is
careful sober foreign policy that takes
account of all interests it's not a game
for amateurs or easy slogans